úgyhogy én ezt látom egyébként a a
sikerkulcsának hogyha úgy tetszik a
városháza szempontjából is hogy ne
szakadjunk el az emberektől folyamatosan
menjünk konzultáljunk ne négy évente
jelenjünk meg ne négy évente döbbenjünk
arra rá hogy ugyanaz a kátyú egyáltalán
nem tömődött be ne négy évente mondják
azt a városakok mert elmondják nem
félnek ők hogyát de polgármester úr ön
négy éve volt itt utoljára akkor is
meglepődött hogy itt van egy nagy kátyú
és most is jön és meglepődik és ezek az
emberek el mondják é azért mondják el
mert kisközösség és ismernek és tudják
hogy velem bármikor találkoz őszinték
őszinték az emberek